la vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner salió a la ofensiva este lunes
en el marco del juicio oral por la
llamada causa vialidad su defensa pidió
recusar al fiscal diego lusianni y a uno
de los miembros del tribunal del juez
rodrigo giménez uriburu el argumento es
que ellos participaban juntos que se
conocían y participaban juntos de un
equipo de fútbol amateur que competía en
un torneo que se desarrollaba en la
quinta en un predio que pertenece al
expresidente de mauricio macri y esto es
parte de un argumento más general de la
defensa que considera que el juicio es
una suerte de persecución motivada
políticamente en todo caso y no hay
resolución hasta el momento de ese
pedido de recusación pero continúan
todavía los alegatos de la fiscalía que
estaban en su cuarto día y acusan a
cristina fernández de kirchner y a otros
doce imputados de delitos cometidos en
el marco de obras viales y obras
públicas en la provincia de santa cruz
entre los años 2003 y 2015 los delitos
supuestos de los que se los acusa son
defraudación a la administración pública
y asociación ilícita todavía quedan unas
cinco jornadas para que la fiscalía
presente sus argumentos y luego será el
momento de la defensa de los acusados
que todos dicen y aseguran ser inocentes